hey guys I'm a be sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen and I'm back with my
friend avi Langer Pepitone so we are
going to be trying some more of those
crazy diets that you guys been sending
to us and I recently was online and it
came across a reddit thread entitled
what geared and great things to beat on
keto and I mean I get it like the pedo
diet is becoming like a huge fad
basically it's all about high fat low
carb low low low carb yes 80% fast so
theoretically you're burning your
burning fat for energy instead of
glucose which is you're starving your
body of glucose and and our brain
functions optimally on glucose so when
you starve it of its favorite food it
gets a little hangry and makes some
pretty questionable decision I hope
you're hungry I hope that I don't mind
yeah that's dusty some of that coffee it
is I know oh no no my they go scorched
so here we've got some heavy cream with
bullion and and some cracked black
pepper
oh yeah that's gonna make it much much
better apparently it tastes just like
cream of chicken soup oh my god it has a
feel oh yeah always
well I can't no you got to get a piece
of film Oh No
I'm sad for this person yeah I'm really
sad that this beautiful cream that I
know I have a stuff like seven bucks
worth of cream and I made a chocolate
mousse is not gonna need a hell of a lot
of things
so if you didn't get enough soup in
round one a B we're going up for round
two
basically I prefer outlet what we have
here is is some clear bra the user
recommended either beef or chicken or
vegetable if you like with mayonnaise
I'm not against mayonnaise but this is
not an appropriate vehicle for Mayo
what is it doesn't even matter Falls and
orange juice no okay
dip the tip and then give her like that
how's that so where would you do that
this seems like something that some poor
starving students came up with and you
know right in the middle second semester
when when the budget was getting low you
know ramen noodles and yes for God's
sake it's like a buck just let me put
them in there anything oh is this it
this is this is the meal we've got we
got some butter some veggie night Center
and some cheese and and our reading user
suggests that we put a load of butter
some Vegemite all the piece of cheese
and fold it into a cheese sandwich
thingy call it a day and of course they
go with the good quality stuff because
you know keep the clock and keep it a
classy here on reddit all right all
right go for it so a load of butter so
I'm assuming that means did I so
I coached my tooth
Oh No haha come back I'd leave your
support
oh god no no our reddit friend here
suggested that would hurt her family
spaghetti she just eats the meat and the
sauce but on cottage cheese its lenient
well we got this won't do
spaghetti squash like spaghetti squash
zucchini noodles there are so many other
an alternative to clothes cheap yeah
only Jess happy no that's sick how about
just eat the tomato sauce with a yeah
separately and then have the cottage
cheese for dessert that would be that
would be the reasonable thing to do but
these reddit people are slots if my
husband saw me do this he'd be like
that's it that's pretty clear indication
that this at the end of the relationship
it needs to go yeah
so when we got here we got interrupted
Oh anything discolor hospices it has to
taste good I'm excited
so these are called the fastest to take
ever basically it's just cream cheese
roll involved and then rolled into
sugar-free jell-o mix sugar-free jell-o
sugar-free jell-o okay I mean I have to
everyone that one going and one red yeah
no that's awful
and why did I see falsies but for the
love of god this is not gaudy mtk her if
you like
it does feel like a little bit like
play-doh like children kids would like
they're like indeed wha panic so I'm
just gonna enjoy myself here for the
next hahahahahaha that was beautiful
look it's like an octopus oh my brain is
little starved for scars so I say we go
we go grab like a slice of cake yeah
real one well guys I hope you enjoyed
watching Abby and I torture ourselves on
the keto diet we did not enjoy doing it
no we did not obviously just like look
at the paleness I live in therapy for
weeks after this but if you loved it be
sure to give us a thumbs up leave me a
comment below some of the crazy diets
that you've seen on reddit it's pretty
sad probably a pot yeah yeah definitely
subscribe this channel and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen
[Music]